[Música]
la rusa gazprom declaró déficit de
suministros de gas amenazado con más
cortes a la unión europea mientras tanto
el bloque sigue buscando alternativas el
líder de emiratos árabes unidos está en
francia y los 27 acordaron duplicar el
flujo de gas desde azerbaiyán las
movidas que buscan soluciones con los
giles son criticadas desde las
conversaciones del clima en berlín
en eeuu comenzó el juicio por el tiroteo
más mortífero en llegar a los estrados
nicolás cruz se declaró culpable de 17
cargos por la matanza de parkland
ocurrida en una escuela secundaria en
2018 ahora los jueces determinarán su
condena
se cumplen 28 años del atentado a la
asociación mutual israelita en argentina
el 18 de julio de 1994 un atentado con
bomba destruyó el edificio de la amia
dejando 85 muertos más de 300 heridos
tenemos reporte desde las
conmemoraciones con nuestro corresponsal
en buenos aires
bienvenidos de nuevo a las noticias
internacionales aquí en france 24 los
saluda maría clara calle iniciamos
hablando de la crisis energética que
enfrenta europa y es que la agencia de
noticias reuters conoció una carta en la
que la estatal rusa gazprom advirtió que
entró en estatus de fuerza mayor y que
por déficit de suministro de gas podría
incumplir sus obligaciones con el 'viejo
continente' la misiva fue entregada a
uno de los mayores importadores de
alemania y elevó la preocupación por la
crisis energética de cara al próximo
invierno mientras tanto los líderes
europeos intentan buscar otras fuentes
de combustible distintas a las rusas hoy
el presidente francés emmanuel mayo se
reunió con su homólogo de emiratos
árabes unidos mohammed bin zayed
al-nahyan en parís firmaran un acuerdo
de suministro de gasóleo además ambos
países podrían acordar una asociación
energética para identificar proyectos
con hidrógeno de energía renovable y
energía nuclear por otra parte del
primer ministro italiano mario draghi
viajó a argelia para buscar un acuerdo
energético mientras que la unión europea
y azerbaiyán firmaron un pacto para
duplicar las importaciones de gas
natural hacia el bloque de los 27
por lo tanto la unión europea ha
decidido diversificarse más allá de
rusia y recurrir a más a socios más
confiables y me complace contar con
azerbaiyán entre ellos
el proyecto energético iniciado por
azerbaiyán y respaldado por la unión
europea y respaldado por nuestros socios
cambia completamente el mapa energético
de europa en plate y change energy +2
ante este panorama alemania también
busca nuevas fuentes energéticas hoy el
canciller olaf scholz y el presidente de
egipto abdel fattah al cis y acordaron
cooperar en la construcción de la
economía del hidrógeno esto en el marco
del diálogo climático de petersberg que
inició este lunes en berlín como parte
de los diálogos previos a la cumbre del
clima cop 27 que se realizará en egipto
en la apertura
scholz y el secretario general de la onu
antonio guterres afirmaron que la crisis
energética desatada por la guerra en
ucrania no debe significar el
renacimiento de la energía fósil y esto
a pesar de que alemania ya reactivó las
centrales eléctricas de carbón y de
petróleo tendrá sus haciendas esto lo
que no debe pasar nos ahora es que nos
deslicemos hacia un renacimiento global
de energía fósil y del carbón en
particular nadie puede estar satisfecho
con el hecho de que aquí en alemania la
proporción de generación de energía a
base de carbón está aumentando de nuevo
como reacción a los cuellos de botella
inminentes en el suministro de gas esto
hace que sea aún más importante dejar
una cosa muy clara esta es una medida de
emergencia temporal que no irá en
detrimento de nuestros objetivos
climáticos lo mismo se aplica a las
inversiones en infraestructura de
restricción indicasen host puntual epson
sus excelencias hace 8 meses salimos de
la cob 26 con 1.5 grados para soporte
vital desde entonces su pulso se ha
debilitado aún más las concentraciones
de gases de efecto invernadero el
aumento del nivel del mar y el calor de
los océanos han batido nuevos récords la
mitad de la humanidad está en una zona
de peligro por inundaciones sequías
tormentas extremas e incendios
forestales ninguna nación es inmune sin
embargo alimentando nuestra adicción a
los combustibles fósiles lo que más me
preocupa es que la enfrentar esta crisis
global no estamos trabajando juntos como
una comunidad multilateral maute la
troca camioneta y mientras la unión
europea enfrenta una crisis energética
dorada por la guerra en ucrania en este
país continúan los enfrentamientos kiev
advirtió que los rusos se están
reagrupando en la región del donbass los
informes aseguran que las tropas de
moscú priorizan los avances alrededor de
bach mut e incluso las milicias pro
rusas del lugar aseguraron hoy que ya
tienen el control operativo de shivers
hasta allí llegaron nuestros enviados
especiales catalina gómez ángel y oriol
andrés gallardo
el fuego de la artillería va dejando
columnas de humo a su paso y con el
grandes extensiones de campo quemado
hasta hace unas semanas la batalla
estaba en una vía paralela y hacia la
ruta del visitante y severodonezk se ha
trasladado a este lugar cada vez más
cerca hacia las ciudades de florian y de
back wood y ahora se añade un dramatismo
más ya los campos están amarillos la
cosecha está lista para ser recogida y
cuando cae la artillería se prende el
fuego en estos cultivos roban muestran
lo escrito de algunos de los cohetes con
los que son atacados nosotros aquí llegó
inscrito un modelo 332 dice asegura que
este tipo de bombas racimos que son
prohibidas en la guerra son las que
están usando para operaciones ofensivas
estos hombres de la brigada 14 llevan
casi dos meses sosteniendo la posición
de las cercanías de la población de
shivers estratégica para la defensa de
las ciudades de bach multi es lo bianco
ellos pararon en pie pero no aquí están
intentando penetrar por este terreno
todo el tiempo como serpientes y
nosotros no tenemos otra opción que
detenerlos matarlos
el ministro de defensa ruso aseguró que
el 16 de julio se acababa ese parón
operativo de las fuerzas rusas la
realidad es que en los frentes de
batalla del donbass este parón no se ha
sentido y aquí dicen que siguen viviendo
el mismo infierno que vivieron en la
lucha de severodonezk ilicic ans
en esta vida decenas de hombres y
armamento se mueven tanto apoyo a la
defensa
las poblaciones de alrededor son
atacadas permanentemente y en la
retaguardia decenas de equipos médicos
están listos el doctor hugo asegura que
las posiciones de esta zona están bajo
constante fuego
la pausa operativa tenemos mucha gente
habilidad que llega desde las posiciones
del frente no tantas como antes pero
casi todos los días tenemos alguna
[Música]
la permanencia algunos civiles en la
zona hace aún más difícil la labor de
los equipos médicos el doctor vladimir
pasa horas en esta posición a la espera
de pacientes momentos antes del
encuentro atendió a tres niños heridos
en una vivienda pocos metros de donde se
encontraban sus imágenes registradas en
los teléfonos son imposibles de mostrar
por su crudeza
y los niños son los más horribles de
este trabajo me acostumbré a los adultos
a los soldados heridos haber mucha
sangre pero con los niños es muy difícil
en esta vía los anuncios de un
recrudecimiento de la ofensiva rusa
parecen palabras vacías aquí la guerra
nunca se detuvo
europa padece altas temperaturas en la
segunda ola de calor que ha vivido en
este mes francia y reino unido- entraron
en alerta roja superando incluso los 40
grados centígrados en lugares donde
históricamente nunca se habían alcanzado
estas cifras incluso el aeropuerto de
luton en inglaterra se derritieron sus
pistas
la ola de calor asola al viejo
continente un momento crítico en francia
15 departamentos en alerta roja los
evacuados por los incendios forestales
superan ya los 16.000 en la región de
girón al suroeste las llamas recobraron
intensidad por lo que las autoridades
piden extremar las precauciones
agua
jude vamos a tener una jornada que va a
ser complicada ligada a las temperaturas
pero también ligada al cambio de la
dirección del viento lo que significa
que ciertas zonas que hoy no se han
quemado durante el día o al menos el
final del día es probable que lo hagan
duret sin un tramo por su parte la
comisión europea prometió movilizar la
asistencia necesaria para paliar los
efectos de esta ola de calor a medida
que surgen más y más incendios
forestales en toda europa la comisión
europea sigue trabajando incansablemente
para movilizar la ayuda a quienes la
necesitan por supuesto seguimos
vigilando la situación durante esta ola
de calor sin precedentes y seguiremos
movilizando el apoyo que sea necesario
este lunes el presidente del gobierno
español visitó algunas de las zonas más
afectadas por los incendios y se refirió
al cambio climático como el fenómeno que
está detrás del catástrofe en españa'
las llamas ya dejan dos víctimas
mortales quisiera trasladar una
evidencia y es que el cambio climático
mata mata personas como hemos visto mata
también nuestro nuestro ecosistema
nuestra biodiversidad y también destruye
los bienes más preciados del conjunto de
la sociedad que se ve afectada por estos
incendios sus casas sus hogares sus
negocios sus ganados reino unido también
ha empezado la semana bajo la alerta de
temperaturas extremas para algunos ya es
momento de aprender a convivir con esta
nueva realidad hacen
creo que el cambio climático está
definitivamente ocurriendo tenemos que
hacer algo al respecto pero aparte de
eso sólo hay que aprender a vivir con él
es toda
europa vive su segunda ola de calor en
menos de un mes con temperatura récord
medidas de emergencia y un balance
trágico de víctimas de europa nos vamos
a eeuu y es que este lunes inició el
juicio por el tiroteo de parkland el más
mortífero que ha llegado a los
tribunales de ese país en 2018 el autor
confesó nicolás cruz
a la escuela secundaria de marjorie
stoneman douglas y mató a 17 personas
con un rifle ar-15 ahora cruz podría ser
sentenciado a cadena perpetua oa pena de
muerte mientras los familiares de las
víctimas piden justicia marinas ardillas
trae un recuento de los hechos
a continuación de un largo y doloroso
proceso judicial se trata del juicio
contra nicolás cruz por el tiroteo
masivo en una escuela de parkland
florida el 14 de febrero de 2018 el
joven de entonces 19 años regresó a la
escuela de secundaria marjorie ty stone
man douglas ya que había sido expulsado
meses antes por problemas de conducta y
abrió fuego con un rifle semiautomático
durante casi seis minutos asesinando a
14 estudiantes y 3 empleados e hiriendo
a otros 17 después salió del edificio
sin ser detectado y fue arrestado una
hora más tarde caminando por una calle
residencial parkland fue uno de los
tiroteos masivos más mortíferos en eeuu
y nunca antes un tirador masivo en el
país había sobrevivido para enfrentar
los cargos su destino está ahora en
manos de un jurado cuyos miembros
decidirán si merece la pena de muerte o
si pasará el resto de su vida en prisión
cruz se declaró culpable en octubre de
17 cargos de asesinato en primer grado
en los últimos años emitió varias
misivas a los familiares de las víctimas
pidiendo perdón una comisión de
investigación estatal descubrió fallas
de las autoridades policiales el día del
tiroteo incluso el fbi fue acusado y
tuvo que indemnizar las víctimas puesto
que varias pistas como su fascinación
por las armas y advertencias de personas
cercanas al asesino indicaban que cruz
tenía intención de atacar el tiroteo e
inició un movimiento nacional de control
de armas que se extiende hasta hoy
tenemos que hacer más que eso ya hemos
pasado por esto durante años y años
y es que este tipo de tiroteos masivos
contra escuelas se cierran sucediendo en
eeuu el último el 24 de mayo en igual de
texas una masacre que acabó con la vida
de 19 estudiantes y los maestros a
propósito del tiroteo anual de se
conocieron las imágenes de las cámaras
que llevaban los policías en sus
uniformes y que muestran la lenta y
desordenada respuesta de las autoridades
esto hace parte de un informe elaborado
por un comité de la cámara de
representantes de texas y que detectó
graves errores de coordinación entre las
fuerzas de seguridad locales estatales y
federales los cerca de 400 uniformados
desplegados en el operativo se demoraron
más de una hora en abatir al tirador
salvado ramos el reporte afirma que una
acción temprana hubiera salvado la vida
de algunos de los 19 niños que murieron
junto a dos profesores
y una procesión de 52 autobuses
escolares vacíos salió de beige a texas
en protesta por las masacres contra
niños en ambientes escolares los
vehículos fueron adornados con coronas
florales decoraciones y las letras museo
infantil de la asociación nacional del
rifle el convoy de una milla de largo
representó con sus asientos vacíos a
cuatro mil 368 niños que han sido
víctimas de la violencia armada desde
2020 y se dirigió hacia la casa en
houston del senador ted cruz quien es el
principal receptor de fondos para
cabilderos de armas en el estado de
texas
se cumplen 28 años del atentado a la
asociación mutual israelita argentina
amia una institución comunitaria de la
colectividad judía argentina el 18 de
julio de 1994 un atentado con bomba
destruyó el edificio de la entidad
matando a 85 personas y dejando a más de
300 heridos en la conmemoración de este
lunes en buenos aires las víctimas
volvieron a pedir justicia allí estuvo
nuestro corresponsal natalio q soy
con la consigna volvemos a pastel se
lleva adelante este acto aquí en la
ciudad de buenos aires para ser en la
calle en la que se encuentra el edificio
de la asociación mutual israelita
argentina es el nuevo edificio del
antiguo edificio también estaba y fue el
que fue destruido por el atentado con
bomba en
1994 y la vuelta a pastar tiene que ver
con que durante los dos años de pandemia
de kobe 19 más duros no se pudo hacer en
forma presencial este acto conmemorativo
y de pedido de justicia por las 85
víctimas mortales los más de 300 heridos
causados por ese atentado el más grande
en su tipo en argentina uno de los más
importantes en américa latina' aquí en
argentina cuya comunidad judía es de las
más grandes del mundo y las más
importantes número de aquí de américa
latina' así llegamos al final de las
noticias pero los invitamos a que sigan
con nosotros
[Música]